step one is assess the hair
i think it's okay all right hey what's
up guys my name is the channel welcome
back to the game engine
series so last time we took a look at
the native script component and writing
scripts natively in c plus wells in
general check out that video if you
haven't already
and today we have some of that code to
undo because
that episode we i don't even want to
talk about it too much
in fact i blame i blame these guys these
guys are the problem let me quickly
switch to a different overlay that can't
see chat
those those guys were the problem i'm
joking
um so basically what we did last time
and this is actually going to be a good
way to look at the code here
what we did last time was we basically
talked about adding
this script class so we now have a
scriptable entity which we can
kind of inherit from we can we have a
native script component that we can use
to actually add behavior to in to an
entity as you would expect from a script
but it's a native script
in the sense that it's actually running
in c plus it's not like a you know c
sharp lower whatever external language
script is just a native script right
here in c plus plus
which comes with all those native
bonuses including
performance and like the whole hazel api
is at your disposal
and it's just it's it's a good way to go
especially if you want to write a small
game maybe
in c plus plus and you don't want to
have a whole like
language runtime running there in the in
the um
in the first place i don't even know if
that makes sense anyway
so the problem with what we did was that
we wanted to be really smart about it
and specifically the reason we did this
is because people tend to hate on
virtual functions
a lot and i actually have in my whole c
plus series i have a specific episode
that i want to address
um that i want to use to address virtual
functions because people
again love to hate on virtual functions
think they're incredibly slow or you
can't use virtual functions here
because you know going through the v
table all those redirects they slow you
down way too much blah blah blah
and there is a little bit of truth to
that but the problem is it's
blown out of proportion a lot of times
virtual functions are not that bad and
in a lot of cases they're totally
acceptable to use you know i think that
the days of writing high performance
like the days of being like okay virtual
functions are banned in my game engine i
think that those days are over
and i mean i use them all the time i
definitely like using them all the time
if you look at
any part of the like rendering api you
know
such as this you know it's made of
virtual functions and those are
rendering calls
so clearly that's a decision there by me
that's like okay we don't really care
about virtual functions too much
which is why uh not using them here
doesn't really make sense
so what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be going back on what we did
last time it was kind of cool to look at
this stuff
i guess maybe taught you something but
we're going to be going back
and actually making it so that this
scriptable entity provides some virtual
functions for us
so if we look at what we needed here we
had an oncreate and on destroy
and an and an on update function so on
create
we're going to be just creating a whole
bunch of virtual functions here i'm
actually going to mark them as protected
inside the scriptable entity class uh
the only
the only thing that really should be
calling them apart from well protected
because we might want to override them
obviously now in our subclass
but um the only thing that really should
be calling them is the
scene and seen as a friend so this is
fine
so on create on destroy and on update
with that
time step tim step
time step okay and by providing
a body here as well we're just making it
so that we don't have to
like implement it we don't want to make
them pure virtual because obviously you
might not want to have an
on destroy function inside your entity
or something like that
so these can now kind of go away like
and by kind of i mean they can literally
go away we don't need them anymore
because we just call you know the
virtual function
normally via the pointer like you would
any other virtual function it's really
easy
however we do need these now these at
the moment i did write as capturing
lambdas and i don't really uh you know
i don't really mind that too much
but in the interests of not using scd
function because again
i don't think std function is
particularly bad to use but technically
we could easily just use a
function pointer it's not that difficult
to use and it would result in much
cleaner code generation from our
compiler because it's not a whole class
with a billion things going on
as you can see i mean this this this is
huge right so instead of that we could
just use something a little bit simpler
and to do that we can write a function
pointer so
what we what we still need out of out of
all of this is we still need a way
for our scene class on scene
start to be able to instantiate
our script so this is like a deferred
instantiation we don't want to
instantiate the script so i just
accidentally
closed my solution explorer
what what a terrible move how do i get
that back
this episode was going so well i can't
believe what did that
where is my solution explorer it's not
okay i found it okay i found it it's
fine i don't need to edit the video
it's fine um it controls that i like
chat over there okay anyway
sorry seriously recording a video um so
uh
i don't remember what i was saying um
everything's a disaster
we don't want to instantiate the script
here we don't want to be like new camera
controller at because you know we don't
want to create this
at the time of creating our code inside
on attach for this editor layer
this is clearly something that should be
instantiated at runtime and there are
specific reasons for that for example
uh script instances script classes might
have
variables that we want to deserialize or
load from somewhere
and ultimately we might not have that
data yet
to actually create that entity at this
point in time so we don't want to create
it now and then
create it again later or do weird things
like that we want to instantiate it when
we start our scene i think that
that makes sense and so to in order for
that to actually work we basically need
to write a little lambda here
that says this is the code i want you to
run this is my deferred code that i want
you to run to actually
create a new instance of this particular
type
so to do that we still need this
instantiate function
and in fact i gave it a slightly better
name i think i called it instantiate
script
when i ran through this code briefly
with with the stream
um and so we have instantiate script and
we have destroy script
because that's really the two functions
that we need
and then what these are um so i changed
them to be non-capturing and what we do
here is essentially return
a new t but we will have to cast this
unfortunately into the right type a bit
later on
this becomes a function pointer that
returns a
scriptable entity pointer um because
obviously we're turning that here so
instantiate script
becomes and displacement as well
incentive script it becomes
uh a function pointer
which looks something like this i hope
right yes
maybe i think that's actually right i
think it's just oh
he nailed it okay function pointers are
always the syntax is always a little bit
hard to write which is why
some people like to either use typedef
or using just to actually define the
type first so you can actually do
something along the lines of this if you
want to and then later use
this as the actual instantiate script
function but of course in this case i
feel like that's just a bit
too verbose it's just two lines of code
for no reason so i like to write it
out like this even though i feel like
they could definitely have improved on
this syntax
okay so this is a void function
called um destroy script
uh and then this what this is going to
do is actually take in a pointer to
itself it's going to take in a pointer
to a native script component
which can be odd because like i mean we
are calling it
you know from itself but because it's a
non-capturing lambda it doesn't actually
have access to this like any other
function would uh and so we're basically
simulating
this right we're simulating the whole
member function call by just making it
actually taking a pointer here to a
native script component
um and i'll call this uh a native script
component here
and then what we're going to do is
delete um native component
instance we don't need to pass this to a
t pointer because now that it actually
properly inherits
speaking of which this should have a
virtual destructor
which uh it doesn't have so let's make
that happen
um virtual destructor
so now that it has a virtual destructor
we can just delete the actual instance
as a scriptable entity pointer we don't
need to do any casting
and we can set the instance to null
this is very useful for debugging and
stuff like that otherwise we could have
just taken in the actual
scriptable entity pointer instead of the
native script component pointer
but i think this leads to slightly more
robust code
okay that's it i believe now if we try
and compile this i'm pretty sure this
line will not compile
because we're not casting it to the
right type let's
quickly go into the scene class though
and rewrite the rest of our code
so instead of doing all of this stuff if
the instance doesn't exist
and again i'm going to stress this again
but this stuff will
um move to
scene on scene play
or something like that right this stuff
should happen on scene play
this should not happen in the update
loop but we don't have a scene play at
the moment so we do it this way
and then what this will actually do is
call the instantiate
script instantiate script function which
of course returns
the new instance so we'll have to assign
it like so and then uh we'll create an
entity out of it i guess we'll we'll run
the oncreate function which again we do
really easily now all we have to do is
do
uh is just do this
on create and that's it so ncs
and so the native speaker component
instance oncreate and then on update
function again
don't need to do any of this this just
becomes
uh this just becomes
on update like that
with the time step and oh i pressed
something okay
and then i think that's it um and then
obviously the last thing we want to do
is actually call on destroy and destroy
but again this is something that would
happen on scene stop
we don't have a scene stop at the moment
until we do i'm not even going to bother
implementing that
yes it is technically kind of a memory
leak but we only
we only start up the scene at once at
this point in time inside the editor
there's no
way to like start stop the scene and
then keep keep doing that
so it's really not a problem at all and
it will be implemented later okay i
think that is pretty much
it as far as this goes um
yeah let's just try and compile
everything here and we'll see if this
actually
works because i believe it should fail
to compile
yep so see it's upset that we're trying
to uh
convert i don't know we're returning a t
pointer and
it i guess it wants a scriptable entry
point i'm not sure basically what we
need to do
is downcast this and i'll use that
static cast for this
we need to downcast this into a
scriptable entity pointer because that's
what the function should return even
though obviously they are kind of the
same type
because a camera controller here is a
scriptable entity and camera control of
course is t
in that case okay here we go take two
does this work it should work
let's run this now so now we're using
virtual functions
instead of using function pointers you
can see we can still move our camera
like we did before
flipping to the other camera it's there
another another test
that we could do as well is to make sure
that we can actually attach
this same script to multiple entities so
can we attach this to our second camera
by just copying that line of code there
and hopefully now what should happen is
well it'll look the same
right but then when i flip cameras the
square doesn't move
because the cameras have both been moved
the same way
and i guess what we could have done is
actually instantiated this
like created these cameras of different
transforms i don't know if it's worth
doing that
um i don't know if we can be bothered
doing that let's see second camera
active scene
uh yeah we won't bother doing that but
you you could
have actually no okay well we there's a
lot of fun stuff we can have with this i
just
don't think that it's worth
demonstrating uh in this particular
episode
but uh obviously you know you could do
some cool stuff and that might be
something that you want to try out so
for example in oncreate maybe you can
get the transform
and assign a random value to like a
transform between a certain you know
let's just do it
because i was gonna i was getting a bit
a bit annoyed at that anyway
um the problem is we don't really have a
random number generator so
i'm already regretting this but let's do
this let's do transform three
zero equals uh
let's do um let's see can we
can we do well i can just do rand mod
like
ten times 10
minus 5 and we might need to seed the
random number generator
let's just let's just see what happens
this is a complete mess
um but let's see if this actually works
i think it may have i just don't know i
think 10 may have been wow we're at 65
yeah that that escalated sorry that's
not what i meant
um mod 10 yeah i don't need to actually
do that let's do this
i forgot that it wasn't between 0 and 1.
i think the mod 10 i yeah anyway
whatever yeah so that's there and you
can see the other cameras actually at a
different location if i move them
they're always going to be at different
locations so it's a really quick
way to just you know make sure that
oncreate is working properly and also
that we actually have two different
camera controllers here so that
basically concludes that script now
there is one more thing i wanted to
mention
and that is um
that we also have a bit of a bug in the
code that someone has pointed out i'm
going to
put this here um chlori
has uh well apart from changing this
around to being like function pointers
and a few other things have changed here
which uh is basically what we did it's a
little bit different here but
we've kind of changed the whole system
around is removing these whole
ampersands here because if we take a
look at
where we actually use these um which is
in a lot of places to be honest but
specifically in the same class
with end when we
when we use group get and we retrieve
multiple components
if we look at the type of what actually
is returned here and specifically this
is a good example
it returns a tuple it returns a tuple
by value of transform component and
camera component
references right so it returns a tuple
of references
so first of all we definitely don't need
this here
because the tuple itself contains the
references
but also having this here doesn't make
any sense and i'm not sure why it even
compiles
slash maybe it gives a compiler warning
i'm not sure because obviously it's
returning a brand new it's
returning a newly constructed tuple that
is a temporary object
it's it's it's being passed by values so
thanks visual studio that was going to
be all dramatic with the
anyway so this should obviously be
by value like this because the tuple
itself contains the references we don't
need to worry about it
obviously in scenarios such as
this when we like for example this is a
different scenario but
we return this by reference you need to
make sure that you use
auto reference because if you don't it's
going to copy it and then you're not
going to
actually affect the tag component in
this case at all since you'll be
affecting a local copy of it
but in that scenario we obviously want
to do it correctly
so we also need to fix that here here
it's a bit different because and if
you're ever if there's ever a doubt in
your mind
just look at the return type so if you
get in this case returns what is return
it returns
a hazel camera component reference
so if you don't do that you're going to
be copying it
so just make sure that you do it in this
case but when
you use structured bindings like this
with a tuple
obviously the tuple itself internally
contains those references and you don't
need to worry about copying the tuple
because
well you're supposed to copy it it's a
local it's a temporary variable that's
being returned
by value like that okay i think we can
delete this ant example code at this
point
as well as these ridiculous functions
that do nothing
and that should conclude our little
cleanup
i am i am actually going to quickly
check that pull request to make sure i
didn't miss anything one two
no just in two places it looks like all
right great all right cool guys
so that is going to wrap up this video
hopefully uh
we hopefully everyone's on board with
this new way of doing this stuff let me
quickly
fade back into here thank you guys for
watching
um if you have any other questions on
this or details maybe we can discuss it
in the next stream or something like
that
but uh other than that uh don't forget
that you can help support this series by
going to patreon.com where you'll get
access to hazeldev which is a much more
advanced
version of hazel with like c sharp and
like you know
with 3d rendering and what else is even
in there like
an editor you know we're basically
working on that
weekly and we're going to be working on
that weekly on twitch live streams
that are just going to be public for
everyone so definitely join up there if
you want to and then those
um those videos on demand will be uh
available to both twitch subscribers but
only for 14 days because twitch
only saves those videos for 14 days so
i'll be uploading them for patreons onto
a youtube channel forever so anyway
thank you guys for watching
uh next time what are we gonna do next
time we
i think we'll just i don't even know
we'll think of something
i'll see you guys then goodbye
[Music]
you